neuf trains au départ de plaisir grignon
pour paris montparnasse entre 6h30 et
10h30
aucune circulation sur la ligne n en
direction de mantes la jolie
heureusement les conséquences de la
mobilisation sociale sont atténuées par
le ciel bleu et le retour de
températures élevées
les commerçants du quartier en profitent
notamment cette boulangerie avec les
produits rafraîchissant ça joue sur les
ouvriers du matin par exemple ça veut
dire que tout ce qui est le pain au
chocolat du matin la baguette du midi
tout tu t'es différer les gens prennent
pas le temps de sortir pour pour
rattraper effectivement ça le beau temps
c'est radical à chaque fois qu'ils aient
un petit rayon de soleil les gens
sortent profit de la terrasse un petit
café est une boisson fraîche donc ça
compense le reçoit cette épicerie du
quartier plaisir grignon perd entre 15
et 20 % de sa clientèle depuis le début
de la grève
avec l'arrivée des beaux jours il pense
compenser cet effet négatif sur son
commerce la semaine dernière quand et de
beautor et avec des grèves auraient aidé
il n'y avait pas beaucoup de clients
mardi le travail mardi delà des grèves
savoir les beaucoup de mal à y pas beau
coup de colère de la journée hélas hélas
ça va un petit peu ça commence à bouger
un petit peu
d'autres commerçants ne ressentent
aucune différence ils profitent même des
alternatives proposées à la gare de
plaisir grignon avec les réseaux de bus